[Music]
so I would love to start with the the
premise of something that as soon as for
those of you that don't know this
amazing film did the producing love last
year as a rough cut and what struck me
immediately about it was the
premise so I just love to hear from the
both of you as you co-wrote it how did
you come up with that like what was that
spark that became mountains we tell the
story all the time but um yeah we do um
but where do we
start when I moved back to Miami in 2014
I started realizing a shift in the
neighborhood I grew up like around
Little Haiti my mother landed there um
in the 80s when she moved uh um to Miami
it's kind of where all Haitians sort of
start
their um you know American life and so I
was really concerned about what was
going on and um I I tried kind of going
into like Community organizing and
immediately got burnt out and I was just
trying to figure out how to go back to
film to sort of amplify what was going
on uh in the community and and what I
was afraid was happening which is you
know rapid
gentrification um of the neighborhood
uh a couple years
later uh a granting organization ulite
Arts started a cinematic Arts
residency uh where you know they kind of
like kickstarted uh shorts filmmakers
into future
filmmakers and we weren't going to apply
we were kind of like joking about like
different premises we would like apply
with because we didn't really feel ready
to make a feature or worthy of it um um
and so at the time we were working uh in
another really gentrified neighborhood
called Winwood which used to be like a
Puerto Rican stronghold and now it's an
Arts
District uh and one day we were like
leaving the office going to lunch and we
saw a demolition worker who just
finished demolishing yet another house
in the
neighborhood and he said goodbye to his
colleagues and walked across the street
to like the still Suburban part of the
neighborhood and I still was Jo about
premises so I looked at Robert and I was
like okay a demolition worker looks so
close to his work site like he could
walk home and then he I was like okay
we're ready we're ready and so a couple
days later we like pull in all nighter
and we were like the last application in
and uh they selected us so that
started kind of our journey at in late
2018 with this fil I think we decided to
said it in Little Haiti because Winwood
at that time had it was already like so
unrecognizable and so far gone and
gentrification had come and gone and
taken it and so Little Haiti is the next
neighborhood that's that that is
happening to right now in Miami um one
of the next couple um and we wanted to
use the neighborhood as a vehicle to be
able to tell you know all these stories
of all this stuff that Monica and I
think about on a daily basis which is
how racially segregated Miami is and how
um different are lives as the children
of immigrants is from our parents who
are bluecollar workers and very
workingclass and have different
aspirations for what their lives look
like too and you know what success means
to them and what America means to them
and so all that stuff we just packed
into this little story about the
demolition worker crossing the street
and you did it so beautifully yeah uh
something I loved about it is it's like
a slightly unusual structure in that we
break and and we go with aspirant to on
her day and then we spend the night with
Junior so how did you how did you come
up with that structure like when did you
know like this is not going to fit into
a traditional
narrative I think we always like even in
our application to OU we're like this is
not an American Indie we want to make
like a Caribbean story so it's going to
feel the way
Caribbean people are or Caribbean uh
stories are and so we're going to sit in
it and it's going to be hot and sticky
and you know we're going to take our
time with this um and I think with that
we felt really flexible with how we
wanted to structure the film um I think
we just really wanted to spend more time
and and you know we could have stayed
with zavier the whole time but I think
we loved our characters and we wanted
you to see who they were as well outside
of him like you know um I didn't want
ESP Bron to just be there um for
whatever his needs are you know what I
mean like she has a life she's holding
the whole family down by herself um this
is how busy her day is this is how she
takes care of her family this is um what
her talents are you know and and same
for junior I thought it would be also a
good way you know with Junior especially
it's like this is zavia story but how
can we tell
you you know everything that's going on
internally with him so we figured like
him just sort of telling us on stage um
about his life about why things are so
tense at home was the perfect way to uh
get to know him as a really funny
comedian but also someone that's at odds
with his family yeah that was that was
so well done and also just really funny
and I've had the pleasure of seeing the
film three times now and it's funny
every time yeah he's brilliant yeah he's
I'd love to talk a little bit about your
actors and of course you have your
incredible lead here but what was your
approach to Casting um I know that this
is your your first feature as a director
so I'd love to hear about you know your
approach to Casting and also your
approach to working with actors yeah I
have a background in casting so it's
something I feel like I'm strong at M um
and and with this I knew that doing an
open call it's going to be useless cuz I
need like two 50 plus fluent Haitian
speakers in Miami that's going to give
me like five weeks of their lives and
that's not going to be you know the
person with the full-time job so we had
an intern at the time and we just had
her like scrubbing through Haitian
movies at or anything with Haitian
people in it like Netflix shows whatever
and she would like uh bring us clips and
we would just like watch watch them and
we saw this film we were watching for
two other
actors um we're about to turn it off cuz
we didn't feel like they worked and then
we like scrolled like right to this
exact part where atone showed up and he
had you know he was like the friend
character he had like some side role but
something about him made both Robert and
I say at the same time like who is that
um and we did some digging some Facebook
stocking and we saw he was friends with
another uh Haitian filmmaker that we
love who was in town that day for Miami
film festival so we're like we have to
go to that party and we like name
dropped and she's like oh my God I'm G
to give you this number right now um
that's my good friend so she's perfect
wow
really
and then um with Sheila I mean we're
auditioning so many um uh Haitian
actresses but I went to uh a concert
like a show
um and I wasn't planning on it but I
don't know something told me to go that
day and and she showed up uh and she was
dancing she's a dancer she's never acted
before actually um and and I just loved
her look and I knew the people who made
the show so I reached out to them like
can I have can you get me in contact
with her and when she turned on her Zoom
like she already like looked exactly how
I imagined aspiron and and um she's also
brilliant and really funny and can do
improv really well so that was
great and then with Chris um I found him
on Tik Tok a year before we started
shooting like he had some viral video I
knew I always wanted an actual standup
comedian um and so I wrote his name down
on a list and I kind of forgot about him
um but when we did the audition you know
he turned his zoom on and he was like
standing up and he was off book already
and uh one of the first things he said
was like when I read the character
description I I thought you guys were
following me because literally
everything in this like I dropped out of
school I live at home with my parents my
dad and I aren't really on good terms
right now I'm a comedian you know um so
yeah it was just him and he's also never
acted before but he invited us to um a
standup show and like love with so
brilliant you know we were like we were
on the fence also the character we
didn't really know if the character of
Junior was going to be a a good a
talented standup comedian like the
character yet but then we saw Chris and
we were like oh no junior is amazing
yeah and Chris is those he wrote the
jokes you know he actually wrote he
those are his jokes those are his J from
his set from his real set that's amazing
but then also like the rest of I just
want to shout out also the rest of the
ensemble cast Basher San is here
like amaz amazing um as zier's brother
in the in my favorite scene in the movie
The like the Domino scene the party
scene and um you know it's like roles
like this that are like you know we're
like so blessed to have folks like
Basher on set who were able to fly from
LA and donate their time you know and
and and really like Believe in Us and be
there with us and and help like really
fill out the movie and make it what it
really is you know so thank you for
doing that with
us I would love to hear what made you
say yes like what Drew you to this
project what made me say yes um after
the first
conversation um and there's something
about the energy that was uh attractive
that was um titillating is the
word I said okay I'm I can I can be
comfortable with these people and and
they sent me the script it was a short
script it short script it was very short
oh man you know put me to work
you know and you know I I did my
meditation I you know let me just yeah
let me do it you know and it was you
know a month you know I have a brand new
baby she's you know she wasn't full yet
right
um I'm like my baby so you know I went
to Miami and they um in their beauty
their kindness they made my stay uh in
Miami
one one of the most wonderful
experiences I've had as an
artist um yeah yeah thank God you said
yes cuz you were the we were the first
person that we audition and the only
person we auditioned cuz we were like if
we're not doing it with this dude you
have a great film
yeah
yeah yeah and and also I could relate to
the characters you know the you know my
son was an artist you know I could
relate to
um yeah I I could relate to zavier also
you know I'm I'm an artist a Haitian
artist you know I was supposed to be a
doctor you know so I I can relate to all
of it and I okay let's go have fun man
yeah that's that's how and it was you
know
again what blessing thank you guys again
I keep tell thanking them for um you
know taking a chance with me you know
you know for making this thing happen
and you know and I've created new family
you know you you know so yeah I hope
that answers the question it absolutely
does the question yeah and i' love to
dive into the relationship between
Xavier and Junior because for me that's
the relationship that anchors the film
um and I feel like like as an immigrant
myself like you're working through those
pressures that savy articulates so
beautifully when he's like I didn't have
a choice and then in that beautiful
final conversation where he says what I
can give you is Choice how how how did
you develop that relationship was it
always the goal to have it be such a
cathartic
ending uh yeah I think it was well first
of all I think you know junior is an
extension of our own like you know
ourselves as like first gen kids um the
part where uh zavier is like are you
sure you're going the right in the right
direction like literally was said to me
like I felt attacked I was like what do
you mean um and so yeah we we just
wanted to find a way to talk about that
experience of you know we're not
comedians but film making is just as
silly I think so like you know trying to
prove yourself to your family that like
if you just hold on a little bit like we
promised like this is going to make
sense and sorry for not paying
rent you know so yeah we just wanted to
find a way to talk about yeah that
tension and in our own experiences as
Christian um kids and I think that the
end that final
conversation is a dream I think it's a
Fant fantasy I don't think that I we
when we were shooting it um someone on
the camera team who haen was like
listening and she was like I wish my dad
wouldn't talk to me like this like this
would never happen um so yeah I think we
were looking for like a cathartic moment
where you
know a Haitian dad like sort of puts his
pride to the side and like you know
finally realizes that you know his son
as a reflection of him um zavia is just
as ambitious as Junior just they just
have different dreams um and um I just
wanted you know to give that space to
every first gen kid to like hear what
they've always wanted to hear yeah it
was beautifully done like I I agree that
it feels like a fantasy but also earn
fantasy in the story um something else
that struck me was the use of color and
also a lack of color um and there are a
couple of moments that stood out to me
like the the house is white and then
when you go and see where Junior's
working it's also a space that feels
almost desaturated yeah yeah but I
imagine that that was on purpose just
talk about these colors yeah yeah I
think well Little Haiti is a very very
colorful neighborhood um one of the most
colorful most vibrant areas of Miami and
and um
I we use color in the
architecture um to sort of show what the
neighborhood's moving into um and moving
away from and so every time they
demolish something what they build back
up is like stark white you know like so
like slowly like color is being like
drained from the neighborhood uh and
from Miami which historically is also a
very colorful City but um yeah it's just
becoming blend changing it's
desaturating in a weird way the city
yeah yeah so yeah we wanted to you know
show that anywh we can um not only with
his like dream house but for junior
Works um Miami Beach when they go out
there everything's pretty white um so
yeah that was a conscious decision yeah
so I was just wondering like those were
really demolition M how did you pull
that
[Laughter]
off sag reps in the room is that does
anybody work for the screen actor's
guild no okay there were no stunts in
this movie if there's anyone from sag in
here not of course not right let's yeah
it was it was fun I mean the thing is um
demolitions like this happen every
single day in Miami multiple there's so
many demolitions every single day so we
were like we need to there has to be a
way for us to get access to these and we
just we couldn't we couldn't we couldn't
and we had
made hundred calls or something like
that and we you know I put somebody on
it to help me with it and they it was
weeks and they couldn't figure it out
and then finally I was going to pull the
play was that we we had saved it off for
the last week of shooting and I was
almost going to pull the plug and be
like we have to just figure it out and
then come back another time and it's
just you know we talk all the time about
how there's so many movies that don't
want to get made because they challenge
you every single day and this was
definitely a challenge but mountains
wanted to get made
because days before we were going to
pull a plug on the movie um on that
section of the movie that I got a call
like hey I got an A a voicemail from you
a month ago do you are you still looking
for demolitions we have one that starts
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
you can come you can have full access we
were like oh my God thank God you know
yeah um so that's how we did it and um
it was crazy the first day on on the
demolition sites you remember it was
like the machines are a lot bigger than
we thought that they were and they're
right in your face so it was it was
really fun to be there but um kind of
dangerous but really
F well it looks great yeah so great job
um as I previously mentioned this
project went through the producing lab
and you also had support for a number of
nonprofit Arts organizations so I just
loveed it's for you to talk a little bit
about like what role like this type of
support has played during the life of
film um huge huge so we we um we went to
I think the first thing we did well
obviously oite Arts was the first you
know our first supporter for the movie
and the impetus for why the film was
even written and you know so they were
they were unbelievable partners and then
we took uh the film we wanted to we
wanted to put the movie and expose
ourselves to kind of like a national
network of colleagues and so we took the
film to the Gotham we were selected to
participate in the Gotham project Market
which was a week of um industry meetings
to during development um to try to you
know figure out some more um support for
the film and that's how we you know it
was huge I mean we met our sales agent
there and uh who's um Marissa at CA who
helped us amazing and she helped us
Finance the film find financing for the
film and we met a lot of great partners
and colleagues there and then you know
obviously the producing Lab at film
independent was huge because we came in
with a rough cut and we got so much
feedback
from five of my other colleagues that
were also in the lab with us who are
like my good friends to this day and
obviously like we're back at film
independent now which by the way thank
you so much for having us here I mean
it's it's um it's very uh generous and
the lab experience of the lab was very
generous but it really just um Us in
progress in Poland was really cool all
these folks that really like took a
chance on the film and opened us up to a
whole world of possibilities that we
just regionally speaking don't really
have access to New Orleans Film Society
is also like huge supporter of Monica's
and my careers from five six years ago
when we did our first thing together and
they helped support this film so I mean
it just wouldn't have gotten made
without without that support yeah well
i' love to take advantage of the fact
that your editor is here and for y'all
to talk about your collaboration and the
post
process yeah well uh to be honest when I
the script was very
short um it made me a little bit nervous
um but then when I saw the footage it
made me not nervous I felt very
comfortable just like exploring with the
actors what what you all did during the
takes and just like how far could I stay
on it and how far can for example the
scene in the bed with you and and the
wife and they're having this
conversation about Junior and the house
and then it sort of veers off and it
becomes about hot dogs and and I I could
have cut before that but I felt like
that's the heart of the scene in a way
even though it's not the plot so to
speak but just just living in those
moments that are outside of a
traditional narrative and not so
conventional and just really feeling the
texture of these characters that was
something that they trusted me with and
then when we sat down and were cutting
the film and getting it to a picture
lock it was just like really
it's really fun on the scene yeah
Jonathan um is also a writer
director um he makes beautiful genre
films but he also for some reason only
editation
films so he edited um a friend of our uh
Edson Jean's uh first film Ludy uh
almost all in cre oh no part of us in
Creo yeah um you did uh our friends I
did did love I did
T and now I'm
doing but we just really trusted the
sensibilities um not only with you know
these other projects but also with his
own feature yeah um and it's definitely
been one of our favorite collaborations
we had a really lovely um post process
and I know like not a lot of feature
directors can say that it's usually a
nightmare for others but it was so
smooth and yeah we still on really well
we were editing in the oite studio so we
had a projector that we would just and
we would just sit on the couch and watch
it and just talk about many other things
and I I also related to the story My
both of my parents are Colombian
immigrants so I did understand feeling
and the pressures of like being a first
generation kid and so and I already knew
and loved Robert and Monica's work so it
was just you asked me and I was I think
I was like yeah I need to think about it
but then I pretty much said yes right
away like I'll think about it but
yeah and you know I don't know if this
has happened to anybody here that's a
filmmaker but when you watch the First
Assembly cut of the movie it's like the
first time that everything laid out on
the timeline MH uh
unrefined it's like we call it the
suicide cut cuz you want to kill
yourself it's so bad you know but this
is the first time that we watched the
First Assembly and Monica and I were
like holy Jonathan what did you do
it's so
good it was really really good from the
first from the very very F from the
preut you know I think I think the key
is sound cuz it really dictates pacing
and feeling and I think maybe as a
director when I like to see a first cut
it's really hard for me to picture some
of these things like even just the
people outside talking or the cars
driving by like all of that helps build
the world so much or even cues like
phones ringing and I think that really
like helps and and also like the temp
music I think I I chose a lot of those
songs that are playing in the cars and
some of them we change but some of them
we kept and I feel like that just helps
inform the characters too yeah so smart
Monica you have a background as a
creative producer and so I'd love to
hear a little bit about how that
informed your work as a director and
what it what what it was that told you
this story is one that I need to
direct um I think being a creative
producer uh made me feel as though you
know I'm I'm I'm I'm there from like the
script I'm doing edits I'm I'm helping
with casting I'm helping with direct ing
sometimes I'm in the edit so you know I
felt as though like my work um doing
that would
definitely um make this a breeze to kind
of transition to directing not true at
all and I it was like in the middle of
set I was realizing was like oh
like I'm daddy now like but I was mommy
before I didn't realize like producing
is like a a a nurturing
role um and you're taking care of
everyone and you're kind of telling
White Lies to make sure that they eat
their vegetables and you know you're you
know you're you're doing all these
things and and now I'm like in charge
and I I you know it's it's generally you
don't you you only think of of yourself
and you only think of you know what's
best for the vision but I was I felt
like I was able to marry those roles
because is I didn't want to
be like is brus the word like I didn't I
didn't want to
like I didn't want to like bulldoze
every like I I have like a a a pretty
good sense of you know not just
producing but I I've been in wardrobe
before you know I've been a PA I've been
you know I've played a lot of different
roles um on set and so I I wanted to
make sure that I could still somehow
take care of everyone mhm um and make
this a more collaborative set and
um uh make this a set where yes I'm the
director and I have final say but you
know there were several times when you
know um the script supervisor had a
suggestion that we could try or um you
know I remember that time when um it was
one of my favorite times on set when we
were doing the dinner scene and you kind
of stopped and I was like this doesn't
make sense like this translation doesn't
make sense um I don't think that I would
say that like that and we like Okay so
let's stop and think about what you
should say and then all the other haian
crew people on set like was like what
about this and like oh I don't know that
doesn't really work cuz and it became
like this really beautiful cabor set
where you know it didn't have to be
hierarchical but um you know horizontal
instead and I think yeah my work as a as
a
producer afforded me um some insight
into
um the roles of others and and and how
they can collaborate outside of those
rules yeah and I'd love to dive deeper
into your collaboration with and how did
you how did you approach it like how did
you approach to collaborating with your
actors how active were they in shaping
their role
yeah Super Active I mean like they have
said the script was super short but that
was by Design I think
that I don't know we I think it's kind
of the same thing I was just talking
about we we weren't super interested in
like dictating every single word cuz I
think that I don't know I maybe we just
didn't feel confident that um it would
come across or we we wanted it to be
really natural and so we wanted to from
the very beginning do like really
controlled improp mhm so some scenes
were
just um action lines descriptions of
like this is this is what happens in the
scene and we would and then he says
something like this know so this is the
and this is the beginning this is the
end and we have to get from here to here
somehow and we'll figure that out in
rehearsal or we'll figure that out on
you know how to what specifically to say
you know and how did you approach that
as an actor well
this was actually um I worked with
another Haitian director um some of you
might know she
is so when I did uh um um stones with
Patricia I only saw the script the day I
got on set I get onet she wouldn't let
me you know so I had that as a point of
reference and
also like you she said you know we uh um
she give us the latitude to um to travel
with with the character and she guided
us you know this is uh she's yeah she
guided us with
uh yeah with the freedom to take it to
the right place yeah yeah so yeah yeah
we had um a week of rehearsal so we were
able to well they were able to meet as a
family and and B but we were also able
to like almost build the scenes there um
so like that bedroom scene I think was
not there was no dialogue really there
was like some things I I want you to say
this for sure exactly but yeah it's like
Robert said like we're starting here MH
we're going to get to point B and then
we're going to end at Point C so you
know you know who you are you know who
your character is let's get there and
build that Tre and and we
you
know you're not
breathing I'm just thinking about what
you would have had to go through to put
yourself through you know oh yeah just a
vulnerable oh yeah it was um that I made
you too yeah
yeah but I I I
um I enjoyed the journey yeah yeah I
enjoyed the journey or even I think
everyone that we had first of all
Haitians are really funny and that's why
it's so funny movie like just naturally
and so I think I don't know something
about it like we can just do improv
really well so like
Basher I don't even know if you read the
script like you you showed up you all
just gave you my part yeah we gave you a
couple pages and again like it wasn't
all yeah and so what would happen it
says something about the culture as well
too I think I think because
unfortunately there's not enough
reference for aan culture M so it was
necessary to give us enough freedom to
be able to bring the authentic
authenticity of it because there's not
that many references and all we have is
our experiences so it was so beautiful
just like you said she gave us the
freedom but Like a Shepherd she was like
go all right go back this way all right
go back this way and get us to the place
that we need to be and and and
especially for the Haitian culture
because we don't see it as enough um I
hope that they continue to do that
because what happens is when they write
it they take away the moment about the
hot dog they take the moments about all
the moments that you're like oh my gosh
and and as a Haitian watching this it's
so authentic I know if somebody would
have tried to write that down there's no
way they would put that down because
it's a culture thing exactly you know
so yeah I had fun in that scene yeah I
yeah that's great think about your
Domino scene um you know another thing
that we would do is like I would just
like let you good guys go and they're
both so funny and we're fast friends and
we just played off of each other but
obviously the scene was kind of too long
and awkward and and you know I think
shepherding is a really interesting word
to say I was like okay let's do another
one don't say that anymore let's you
know and so every time we do our take it
just be Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
I remember had a scene yeah so it was a
really interesting process but I like
yeah
we what fun what pleasure again no
really these two I'm really thankful to
have had the
opportunity um to work uh under the
direction you know Monica what lovely
and
godess no this is coming from you know
my
experience yeah what love the human
being I I wish I reacted to have an
opportunity to work on the direction so
yeah but hey keep me in mind
okay I want to work some more no it was
just um one of the most Pleasant
experiences that I've had
you know um U as an
actor So yeah thank you so much again
guys yeah thank
you so I'd like to know if anybody in
the audience has a question yes just
first of all I just want to say B guy
yes I appreciate you portraying us not
in a character way with real people uh
it's a very tender story you did a great
job with your cast all you guys um
question to Jonathan being that you
don't speak patient and
cray how was your process editing the
language you don't really grasp yeah I
feel like
the this might sound a little precious
but I think like the film making has its
own language and its own Rhythm um but
that
doesn't that's not always consistent
because I don't know Asian gr so I can't
just live off that but um I had uh Al
plan come in he's another Haitian
filmmaker from Miami and we're all just
like this small community of filmmakers
and we all work on each other's stuff
I've edited his stuff and so he was in
the studio with me translating as I was
cutting and so figuring out how to build
the scenes was hard and it was even
harder because of the language barrier
but um having out there giving me the
the scenes with the subtitles on it
really
helped and then for the English and
Spanish I I know
those okay yes um great film and I
really enjoyed every minute of it and um
one question that I had um the art
Direction was super and the kitchen was
Like Home to me and all the paintings
and the
carvings and the beautiful sculptures I
mean media Direction was like super and
it didn't miss a bit for me so that's
what I like about the aspect of the
colors the inside and outside of the M I
haven't been to little hati but I've
read a lot about it how the community is
dying
genfic and I was waiting for to see the
library but I didn't see it so the
outside library that is big but I didn't
see but that's that's fine but the other
Direct was wonderful M you talking about
the the bookst yeah the book I think
it's in there
actually not the inside but yeah it's um
yeah it's yeah yeah it was it was closed
which happens a lot he's getting old
and you know things are changing um yeah
so production design
um
we both of them were kind of first time
uh art directors or you know
um Helen Pena who's Dominican um is a
filmmaker as well and um Nadia Nadia
wolf was their art director who is a
Haitian artist uh and they work in
textile and installation and I picked
them you know Helen is was I I met Helen
as a community
organizer um
they know Miami they know Caribbean
culture um and uh they were kind of
trying to be a producer but realized
they didn't have a gift for it but like
we're so good at
creating uh spaces they like created
spaces in in many different ways um and
so you know I kind of auditioned them so
to speak talk to them about what's going
on and and they got it immediately and
so we were able to give them
um that space and Nadia I
saw um the same day I saw Sheila I went
to an art show right before and I saw
Nadia's installation where they made
like this table it's like a Haitian
table but like every piece of the table
was like a different textile or a
different material but it was all like
the same culture so I was just like
you're brilliant I just want you around
and so you know together they were
already friends and and you know they
were so precious about so many details
like the bedroom like if you like watch
again like all the Clutter that's like
on the side table was like perfect
perfect to each of the characters like
side of the bed for example or like
Nadia sold the pillowcase you know like
they were like super precious um with
every detail and really happy that that
came across um and it was in my mother's
house too oh okay
I made them stay in the bedroom while we
got there so we took very good care of
it the Vick on the night table the Vick
yeah with the next ticket
yeah
pills I've got way over on time but if
anyone has like one last
question uh I
just how much I feel some that you kind
of expl with how your script was much
more up to kind not interpretation but
just up to finding it finding it with
your collaborators but so much I think
of also the script was just the
performances you get you left so much
unsaid in a great way you didn't overe
explain the culture so it's like I'm not
Haitian but so much of what I saw is
like oh yeah I recognize so many of
these cultural Beats from my just
growing up and when you didn't explain
it you just let it be and you just kind
of let it exist and let the audience
trust the audience they're going to find
it like how much of that was intentional
or planned going into it or was more
like in the edit oh let's cut that out
we don't need to say that or how much
was what was said on set for the
performance you said oh I don't need to
say that anymore when we got to the
edit I I think we didn't like write this
to like I think we wrote this like for
us like for people in Miami for Haitian
so we didn't have to like explain what
things were um
uh because that's not it it
wasn't I don't even think we anticipated
like it would be you know a tiff at film
independent or um but even if it was you
know like one of the films we watched um
when we were developing This was um
Fernando F's I'm no longer here which
was on Netflix and something we loved
about it was that I could tell that it
was like a richer experience
the closer you were to it so like if
you're from the West Coast great if
you're from if you're Mexican but if
you're from Monteray like I'm sure like
there's so many nuances that um are so
specific um that make it like so much
more of a joy and I think that we're
thinking about that like if you're like
a Haitian from Little Haiti like it's
going to be you get everything but even
if you're not you're still going to you
know um you know you're going to
understand and uh the story you're going
to understand this family you know we
don't have to explain uh that they love
each other or we don't have to explain
why there's tension there like these are
very Global themes that we're talking
about even though it's with a hyp
specific culture
yeah to ask a good question but my
stylistic um aspect of the film was like
was text and do radio voices when he's
driving and that talking something
totally different but a regarding and
politics behind it and this is something
that I grew up with and the radio is
always constant and the kitchen was like
perfect for me she's always putting it
on there was always music in the
background but I wanted to hear more
news but the news was when he's driving
that was like brought it back home to me
that the haian politics is always
there so that's why this film was
powerful for me thank you thank
you yeah yeah I think we're just
interested in making sure
that
yeah over I'm so sorry but it was such a
great conversation I'll talk to
[Applause]
[Music]
you